[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about importance of the direwolf so
how stark as well as about faith so
ghost and I'm area in the final season
supportive leagues and of course a few
predictions of mind ghosts will finally
reappear in the final season after we've
not seen him since season 6 he'll fight
beside Jon Snow during the battle for
Vin FL and he'll not be the only doll
out there Namir will also reappear with
a pack of wolves during this battle
their fates will probably meet its end
there as well which might also a share
of their masters fates - with all that
being teased let's just jump in it
starting with a quick recap about
Daryl's dire wolves are unusually large
an intelligent species of wolf a great
dire wolf on a white field is the sigil
of house dark dire wolves are held to be
near mythical in most of the south of
Westeros habitants of the north
acknowledge that their real animal but
they are very rarely encountered there
there have been confirmed sightings
north of the wall by the Knights for
show guarded the wildlings who live
beyond the wall claimed that their walls
can be found in greater numbers in the
haunted forest to the north of the wall
by the reign of King Robert Baratheon
owed our wolf had been sighted south of
the wall even in stark lands of the
north in over 200 years after Eddard
Stark sentences Ville to death for
deserting the Nights Watch and carries
out the execution he heads back to
Winterfell along with his sons Robin
brain his bastard son Jon Snow and his
adolescent bored Theon Greyjoy their
journey the encounters take that on the
road partially disemboweled looking for
what killed it they fight a dead female
dire wolf with an antler P is broken off
in her 12th the female died after giving
birth and her five pups cuddled by the
corpse for warmth
Theon advocates killing the pups but
just to convince the snare that this is
an omen the dire wolf is a symbol of how
stark and that there it has five true
born children other degrees that his
children can have the pups but only if
they raise them themselves with no help
from the servants just as the party
leaves John finds a sixth pup an albino
runt of the litter
still mockingly points out that this one
belongs to John adding to the
speculation that the event is an omen is
the fact that the pups are revealed to
be four males
and two females the same as the stark
children including John this whole event
foreshadowed many major events the death
of Ned Stark leaving behind six children
and just like that Ned Stark's death was
foreshadowed in a very first episode of
the series
Darla was killed by stag which actually
foreshadowed the Robert Baratheon a stag
getting net the wolf killed by inviting
him to King's Landing
well six pubs ever led behind upon the
dialogues that represents Ned six
children a huge amount offense also
believed that it was the three-eyed
Raven who sent a pregnant are both to
the Starks many doubt it was just a
coincidence they just happened to pass
by added our wolf but as many pups as
Ned since there are officers seen only
north of the wall by this theory blood
we even worked into dire wolf and
brought itself of the wall through some
secret passage and the holder of stag
situation was made by him as to why he
wanted to send the devil's to the Starks
it's possible that he wanted to awaken
the word nobility in the stark bloodline
because he knows some of the stark
children will become his successor or
there's also a theory that the holder of
event was meant to warn the Starks for
the events to come there's one very
interesting quote from the books and
many fans view it as a hint supporting
this theory Kathleen says to rod the
wolves are more than most Rob you must
know that I think perhaps the God sent
them to us in father's gods the old gods
of the North five wolf pups Rob five
four five star children six said Rob
there was a wolf or John as well
I found them remember I know how many
there were and where they came from when
Eddard Stark shelled south to King's
Landing to serve as hand of the king he
brings his daughter Stinson Arya along
with their pet dolls
lady in a myriad these are the first
dolls to be seen so far south in
hundreds of years after numiri attacks
Prince Joffrey ah realized her away to
escape execution for attacking the
Prince in her place ladies killed by
Lord Eddard on the command of Robert the
mirror has been travelling the
Riverlands ever since and she leads a
pack of gray wolves
the other generals remain with their
masters until they were killed with the
exception of John's novel ghost who's
still alive
going into the final season has been
officially spoiled that goes till
finally reappear and I just first seen
or two and I Miravalle as well ghost has
not been seen ever since John was
resurrected but the Miria did appear in
the last season all
Amira's brief appearance did not make it
up for their little tune on screen time
during these past few seasons at least
we know ghost is alive and well and he's
the Minerva as the showrunners confirmed
it goes through main demeanor fell with
sense of and Jean left to me Danny a
gemstone according to Game of Thrones
producer Bryan cogman he wrote the scene
featuring ghosts and the show actually
filmed a scene with him first season 7
but they had cut it for budgetary
reasons instead of ghost or sorrow the
showrunners decided to fulfill their
long very wish of having an undead
bearing Game of Thrones basically ghost
role has been cut twice thus far
instead of goes the showrunner said the
rector of episode battle the bastards
also decided that it's better to rather
include a giant which in my opinion was
a good decision since I don't see who
else will be better in breaching the
gates of NFL however I'd be happier if
instead of a vibe err they included
ghosts in season 7 but that just means
anyways the good news is the game
interest production has big in a budget
to include all things would like to see
in the final season hoards the wide
situations Giants and of course narwhals
they've another director of three
episodes of season 8 basically director
of the half of the final season
confirmed it when answering some
questions from the fence on the game
turn subreddit it's not only been
confirmed by nadir that we're going to
see a direwolf in the final season but
it's also been confirmed by a visual
effects supervisor Joe Bauer who told
The Huffington Post that there's not
money now for dragons and Giants and our
roles send much more he confirmed that
ghosts will be back and not just for a
brief moment as Nymeria was in season
seven bauer said oh you'll see him again
he has a fair amount of screen time in
season 8 he does show up
he's very present and does some pretty
cool things by doing some pretty cool
things I imagine goes killing a bunch of
whites fighting alongside Jon Snow and
probably saving him hopefully without
having to sacrifice himself so Jon will
finally reunite with ghost
probably early on in season he'll
probably have a quite a role to play
ghost role probably will not be just
fighting against nat king and his army
there's likely much more der waals have
since the very first episode being tied
up to the Starks in their faiths main
events of the show have been
foreshadowed by them for example Ned
Stark's death was foreshadowed by the
very first appearance of the devil's
about which I talked a few minutes ago
Jon Snow spot for share of Joshua
lineage the outcast of the pack as ghost
was found apart from siblings in much
the same way that Jon as a bastard was
apart from his own goes for share of
that jon is in fact a Targaryen
ghost being an albino shows Jon being
different to the rest of the stark
children and not the great dire wall
showing that he's not a stark there can
be seen many more parallels and
symbolism between other die roles in
their master star children such as Arya
sending the mirror off on her own to
save her life which is basically our
whole story being forced to flee and be
on her own in order to survive Arya
becomes this fearless assassin and
Amelia becomes the leader of a huge
Wolfpack in the Riverlands then we had
senses dire wolf lady who symbolized
senses innocence and desired to be later
I can fit in to Westeros a society and
her death shows how badly that works
semester us summer's death on the other
hand symbolizes the end of summer
victories here as well as the death of
brain stark as we know him brain is not
brain anymore
he is the three-eyed Raven now the fates
and indeed the names of the d'Arles are
incredibly important and as many fans
claim it also holds the key to
absolutely everything that has happened
and will happen to their human
counterparts if the Starks and their
dire wolves so closely linked it seems
impossible that any of them can
ultimately survive if their wolf has
died one fan says this only Arya in John
snows wolves are left
that means brain and sensible both die
before the game turns finale
each of the dead wolves was killed by
someone somehow related to their owners
death reckons dog was killed by Remzi
recon was to Rob's wolf was killed by
phrase Robb was - that means the brain
is going to be killed by White Walkers
just like his boat was and since they
will be killed by stark just as her
Volvo's now it's certainly an
interesting theory but I don't think
sense and brain are going to die or at
least I hope not what I know is that
ghost will finally reappear and play an
important role in the fun season which
you'll likely be saving Jon Snow during
the battle for vinify ghost will
definitely fight alongside Jon Snow in
this battle against the night king and
his army if you look closely on the
official trailer you could even notice
ghosts in the background in case you
missed it pay attention to the left of
Jorah moment when the camera pans when
his guard and bell already face and
you'll notice something that is out of
focus something white and are
wolf-shaped moving around in the
background
it's definitely ghost in my opinion
their summaries Johnston as well when
talking about the battle the bastards
Miguel's Epoque Nick who will also be
directing battle of NFL in season 8
might have hinted that ghost will not
survive it he said obviously a big
battle like that is no place for a
direwolf suppo canning joke then
continued with they're not gonna last
very long I mean look at what happened
to one one the last of the Giants of
course Rob's Darville grave ended just
fine in a number of early battles
so suppose Nick was forced at made that
ghost was in there in spades originally
for the Battle of the bastards but it's
also an incredibly time-consuming and
expensive character to bring to life he
said they ultimately had to choose
between one one in the Darr wolf so the
dog bit the dust however it has been
officially confirmed that ghost will
finally appear again and one can only
hope go survives it Orioles direwolf
Nymeria Veloz appear in season 8 and
she'll most probably also join the fight
for Winterfell and help her brother and
master to defend it area Star Wolf
briefly showed up in season 7 but in my
opinion I marry ischemia was just
setting the stage for something bigger
much much bigger in the books george RR
martin gives the missing Nymeria and her
Wolfpack very much on the minds of
readers via our dreams and news of a
vast pack led by the Miria attacking
stark enemies deep in free territory in
2014 interview it's Mashable martin t is
numerous important role in the final two
books you know i don't like to give
things away
he told with a grin but morton added you
don't hang a giant wolf pack on the wall
unless you intend to use it that pretty
much says it all by itself by mary and
her pack of wolves who appear in the
darkest hour arrived out of nowhere to
try to turn the tide wouldn't it be nice
if ghost also got to fight by his wolf
sister's side just as John will be
fighting alongside Arya
in conclusion ghost is confirmed to
reappear in the final season and here
fair amount of screen time while Amir is
just as likely to reappear both will
reunite with their masters and fight
during the battle for Winterfell
and we could even see ghosts in the
official trailer behind surge or a
moment let me know in the comment
section what do you think about all of
this the thing ghosts in a mirror will
survive Battle of Winterfell or do you
think that the place where they'll meet
our end also tasting the fades the names
to the start their roles hold the key to
absolutely everything that has happened
and will happen to their human
counterparts and as always I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to sub
scribed our channel and they hope the
seen the next one peace